it's funny because sometimes like when I
do interviews I ask like how people are
keeping busy you couldn't be more busy
doing stuff like do you have any time
for homeschooling with the kids or like
how do you fit back and stuff in
literally I like the smartest decision
my husband and I've made in our entire
existence together was we kind of weave
doctor friends in LA and we were like
this is gonna get bad like this is going
to get to where we can't leave like
nothing like this is gonna get bad so we
as soon as we knew we couldn't get on
the lot of NBC for the talk show The
Voice anything we came to Montana and we
were like we'll just in our VRBO we
thought maybe we'll be here for like you
know a few weeks like now two months
later we're still here and we have no
home here like you said we're actually
starting to build a house in the next
couple weeks so we we have no room home
you hear her celery and it's been kind
of crazy but but we're very lucky we
have land at least you know might not
have had bedrooms but we have
four-wheelers and forests to kind of go
in and get outside of nature and not be
trapped you know so we're very lucky in
that sense yeah now I do you I love I
dare you so much I know you said it felt
like the right time for this song to
come out so what what it surprised you
about the reception of the song it's
been up for a couple weeks now you know
I've been in this industry for close to
20 years and it's I mean you know you
have certain expectations when you
release songs at this point you know I'm
saying like I've shown success I've been
so fortunate I just did this project
because I wanted to do it like I've
always wanted to do multi language thing
I've always I love the songwriters for I
dare you I've always wanted a song with
this kind of message that was kind of
globally connecting well before the
pandemic and now we're super overly
connected um but um I've always kind of
wanted this so this was just a project
of like love for me like I really want
I've always wanted to do this so for me
it was a personal kind of victory I
didn't really know what to expect
honestly like releasing a song one in a
pandemic and to you know you have such
certain expectations at this point your
career you know so I had no idea I'm
very very fortunate that it's doing well
so I
and and also just being able to record
with these different artists all over
the the world you know actually one of
them vasya actually is no youna de yeah
arabic but this is actually the first
song she's ever saying in Arabic she
just knows background yeah and and she's
it's like a Moroccan Arabic so it's you
know it's been a really cool thing to
like be able to work with different
artists because we're really lucky I
know artists it sucks because we can't
tour and can't do stuff like that like
in person but we are very fortunate to
have a job that we can still navigate
during this page a lot of people have
lost their jobs you know so we're so
we're really lucky in that sense ya know
yeah speaking of the different language
versions that you did like I'm sure you
know if you had screwed up
pronunciations and certain words people
would have come after you so hard so
what's your you nervously like what have
I got myself into I need to nail like
five different languages
oh no I well and the thing is if I
begged my one thing with this project
was please don't send me all these songs
that wants to record because I will have
a brain aneurysm well so life happens
that I had to record all five different
languages in four days and I literally
cried definitely two of the nights I I
was like I don't know if I could do this
like it was just so hard to you know I
wanted to nail it and as best as I could
obviously I'm you know even me growing
up singing in French it was a different
dialect of French than zazz so you know
different part of France that she's from
that I grew up singing you know even an
opera so you know it was it was a lot of
work but I think when you love something
so much and you want it so bad and your
husband reminds you of this at night
when you're crying you're you know it it
becomes this it became literally I
wasn't lying in that tweet that I sent
out or that message I sent out saying
this is the hardest / favorite project
I've ever been a part of because it's
really hard but the challenge was worth
it you know yeah
so is this so I'm gonna be connected to
new album er just kind of on its own I
mean it was on his own of this
that we it's the first kind of thing we
released but it will definitely it's
definitely leaning into now we already
have several songs for the mini songs
for the album recorded and I actually
just recorded a duet that I wish I could
talk about oh no no I'm gonna guess so
good I have to sing with this person
within the last six months forever and
we love singing together so much it was
so cool how our voices just sounded
together and also kah and so my label
found this perfect song and we just
recorded it and so I'm I think it might
be the next thing we release I'm not
sure but it's definitely on the next
it's it's on the album coming out but um
it's you know for artists like I said it
is kind of a cool time although I'm a
working parent and very busy there are
nights that I have to myself and I get
in the studio and being you know being
kind of on this emotional rollercoaster
kind of healthy for an artist and
creatively
oh so it's creating really cool music at
the same time is it someone you sing on
your talk show it's someone I sang with
but I can't say where it is yeah it's
kind of different flow of a duet as well
you know so it's and it's interesting to
record a duet like you know completely
so far apart from your person but um but
it's it's it's been really cool fun kind
of experience just a nice distraction we
all need distraction and that's it's
been really good for me yeah I think
musically meaning of life is my favorite
album that you've done I know that was
sound that you always wanted to make are
you still gonna go in that direction in
terms of the R&B smile are you going
back popplers you're you're correct in a
bit it's funny this album is kind of if
meaning of life stronger know if mating
of life and like yeah stronger and break
when they had a baby what gets like it's
kind of like there it's all okay because
there's someone there that kind of her
like oh this is kind of like a
contemporary throwback to like the
breakaway days or there's one that's
like could it definitely fit on like the
Droid I just talked to I could have
definitely fit on
meaning of life but it's kind of it's a
little bit of all chapters of my career
this album is shaping sound like that
okay do you have like a timeline when
it's gonna come out here well that's all
timelines are we had a timeline that
might get shot to hell so we're we're
hoping that you know we can pull this
all together in the time that we
expected which is you know near the end
of the year but we you know I want to
make promises because I hate what I do
that and then life happens and then
people like you promised we're hoping
for our regularly scheduled program but
um who the hell knows yeah I saw the
footage on The Voice I guess on Tuesday
night if you're trying to assemble the
equipment the video equipment like how
is it trying to do the voice and talk
show from Montana it was like literally
based first of all the voice in that
package and I knew they were doing
they're trying to get comedy here and
they've got it
like what like person like I I don't
thrive in any scenario when it comes to
technology it's almost as if I pissed
off the technology gods in a previous
life or something like that's how poor I
am in it and like setting up lighting
and saying like I mean and we're not
doing we're not successful at it like
the last live show
I got like so many texts and emails from
friends family going were you having
some kind of bat signal on your chest
with light like it was your chest had
this like beam of light like I was from
cocoon I don't even know if you remember
that movie from bacteria where the light
seeps out of the egg like it was just so
bad we're not good at it but we're
trying I know you only have a couple
minutes left but you want to talk to you
about Kelly okie which absolutely love
like I love the Madonna Like a Prayer
you just did is there yeah is there like
an artist or a song that you won't touch
because it's kind of think who you
haven't done yet because they're like
someone you won't touch
you can see anything no it's so funny um
Garth Brooks is actual on my on my show
and my TV showed he looked I mean he
asked me that same question and I I give
you the answer I gave him I was like
there's not really anything at this
point I won't try I mean it's some songs
are so nostalgic for us like even like a
prayer that's such a nostalgic song it's
such a Madonna anthem I know covering
that song it's gonna be different and
not what everybody expects to hear I
think I just go into it with that
mentality yeah I cover post Malone I
know it's not gonna sound like post
Malone and we're so used to us having
like post Malone but I love music I'm
such a fan I'm like you I love artists I
love music I love you know singing
different genres of music there's really
nothing I wouldn't attempt like there's
definitely things I've done and not
nailed um you know cardi wise one of
them no I do think there's definitely
but I do not only it's not like I'm
trying to perfect some vocal it's it I'm
having fun and it's it it's fun to sing
songs I love so you know I think my
expectations are low in the sense of
like I'm just doing it cuz it's fun and
I love to sing and everybody loves these
songs and even on tour every fan like
Eve when I go to a show I love their
music but I love when they cover another
artists and you get to hear like a
different version of it that's that's
like my favorite